is that mistletoe I'm on the naughty
list
don't tell I'm Santa's second wife
together the invitation said festive
attire I hear you say Merry Christmas
because it's Happy Holidays it's a
holiday party cheer a lot of green see
how I read where's the blue man you like
the Peters I like potatoes Oh lacus I've
had this on hold since July
don't I look fantastic you are a sweater
that's cute oh thank you yes it took my
stylist for hours but obviously it was
worth it oh we're just stopping by so
many parties to get to I get it I'm not
wearing a dress I don't care Jesus
wasn't born in the sequence sure I
dressed up I want white oh this is so
cute
I bet you're freezing is that a real
Christmas tree those are so bad for the
environment did you buy those ornaments
you know you could DIY them it's just
with the money you spend on catering we
could have had a lot of hungry people
but the shrimp was sensational
I don't know why people don't wear red
and green all year they go so well
together we should do a Secret Santa
caroling
let's go caroling I'll Drive do you like
my antlers I order them in bulk you want
I can get you a pair what you've never
seen Mean Girls oh I have one day when
you can have eight yo Sam what should i
hash tag this party